hallo leute wären heute besuch von alina
herkommst alina vor hier aus
berlin-reinickendorf alina hat auch
einen eigenen instagram account zum
deutsch lernen den posten will mal hier
unten und wir stellen heute eine frage
nämlich in welche länder sind die leute
schon gereist
und was war ihr größter kulturschock los
geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo können sie uns helfen wir wachen
dass die leute die deutsch lernen
ja okay also und zwar die frage von
heute ist welche länder haben sie schon
bereist welche länder ich schon bereist
habe da findet eine ganze menge
ich war sehr oft in südkorea
ich war in usa hauptsächlich auch viele
länder in europa spanien frankreich
italien dänemark schweden spanien
portugal griechenland
ich war in asien um konkreter zu sein in
thailand und in lars österreich amerika
indien südafrika amerika spanien marokko
griechenland und ich war auf kuba und in
marokko
also das ist aber ich zum beispiel
zigaretten am unterwegs und war dann
durch polen litauen lettland russland
china japan südkorea vergessen das
machen wir nämlich das wollen wir dir
nachmachen wirklich wie ich habe angst
vor dem fliegen und jetzt habe ich aber
auch eine ausrede von wegen fliegen ist
nicht mehr zu verantworten und deshalb
haben wir uns entschieden jetzt nur noch
zu mit dem zug zu reisen hat
wahrscheinlich umweltfreund umweltmesse
ich keinen sinn aber wir wollen ihn zu
fahren und deshalb freue ich mich so
sehr dass du uns diese route erzählt
dass die gute kann ich wirklich thailand
usa spanien
frankreich norwegen jetzt wenn ich die
alle aufzähle
vietnam china malaysia indonesien also
viel südostasien das alles österreich
polen niederlande belgien schweiz also
ich weiss nicht eigentlich eigentlich
was alle slowenien ist auch sehr schön
kann ich gar nicht richtig aufziehen
also viele in europa zuerst mal die
direkten nachbarländer natürlich in
skandinavien auch schon fast alle länder
außerhalb europas noch nicht so viele
südafrika war ich und amerika genau
russland dann die ganzen damals noch zu
russland gehörenden staaten kasachstan
usbekistan und so weiter und so fort
dann ganz europa dann nordamerika
südamerika viel und was würdest du sagen
weil dein größter kulturschock korea
denke ich ja wohl was war dort so anders
also ganz drastisch an
[Musik]
ich glaube so dass das moderne digitale
und dann und vor allen dingen im
gegensatz zu berlin fällt auf die
servicekultur also in berlin haben ja so
ein bisschen probleme mit dem mit dem
servicegedanken manchmal und in koreas
der kunde wirklich könig also wirklich
kulturschock gibt sicher überall mal
immer mal wieder mongolei war schwierig
muss ich sagen aber kulturschock gibt es
an sich kann ich eigentlich nicht sagen
weil man auf die länder einlassen oder
nicht ich glaube tatsächlich ich habe
einen roadtrip gemacht mit einem freund
von mir und da sind wir über bosnien
gefahren und da war so ganz die straße
war auf einmal mit einem berg und gab
nur schotterweg aber zweispurig daneben
weil die klippe es war schon ein großer
kulturschock und irgendwelche tiere auf
der fahrbahn
sicherlich kultur weniger vom menschen
abhängig aber es spiegelt ja auch
einiges wieder hast du einen
kulturschock in deutschland erlebt
ja wir denken immer dass mieter eine
ziemlich ähnlich sind wie deutsche aber
es gibt noch ziemlich viel unterschiede
das ist immer das zu bemerken
weniger fahrräder zum beispiel hier in
berlin sind natürlich auch viele
fahrräder aber ich denke dass wir in den
niederlanden vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr erfahrungen auf den aufenthalt und
bessere wege bessere möglichkeiten zur
wege ja und wir lernen schon seit wann
man vier jahre alt ist dass man so die
richtung anreisen muss abend hier machen
was hat das für mich so ein bisschen wie
kleine details gerade in berlin ist das
ein bisschen abhandengekommen
der kulturschock ist stoff für mich gab
es ein kulturschock als wir in tirol
angekommen sind abends und nichts mehr
auf hatte und wie einer tankstelle was
zu essen holen mussten
und er sagt er hat noch ein paar salate
und wir was haben wollten ohne fleisch
und der total pikiert reagiert hat was
er gerade haben wir nicht in österreich
gibt es fleisch haben da war also für
mich war es da war ich sehr pikiert also
kulturschock ist übertrieben aber ich
war schon so huy nicht wie in berlin
wir essen wir uns einfach nur durch weil
so viele leckere sachen gibt nur am
essen hier
marica war auch ein kulturschock waren
sie dort im supermarkt nach der
weihnachtszeit ganz großer kritiker wie
so was war der kultur shale alles
leuchtet alles bunt ist nur
weihnachtsmusik ist nur weihnachtsdeko
da ist wie im fernsehen und man glaubt
damals gespielt aber es ist echt indien
indien war der totale kulturschock
komplett andere welt komplett andere
welt
und was war dein größter kulturschock
oder dein größtes abenteuer südafrika
wahrscheinlich
du warst du alleine mit meiner freundin
aber ich war recht jungen 15
und es war kompliziert zu recht zu
kommen oder was hat zum abenteuer
das war ein kultureller schock in dem
sinne dass ich noch nie in so einer
armut ein paar konfrontiert waren es
genau das war der größte unterschied ist
dass man zu sehen genau woher kommst du
denn ursprünglich das leben in der
schweiz in zürich und kommt dir was an
deutschland anders vor sehr auf jeden
fall die die menschen sind sind anders
und wie soll ich das beschreiben es
irgendwie realer in berlin zum beispiel
als in der schweiz in der schweiz ist
alles viele irgendwie schöner und also
schöner nicht so einfach ich meine dass
die die vibes so sind die irgendwie ein
verklemmter viel erinnern und hier ist
es auch real ein dem sind auch
gefährlicher vielleicht und und einfach
ernster die die ganze situation und man
sieht manche sachen die man nicht in der
schweiz sehen würde ja okay gut gerade
in berlin
vielleicht auch eine extremsituation
extremer her ist als in der schweiz zum
beispiel
und welches land hat sie am meisten
beeindruckt kuba weil ich den kontrast
zwischen arm und reich dort so präsent
fand also da gibt es richtige hotel
hochburgen mit all-in budgets und 19
meter weiter und da leben die menschen
in kleinen hütten also sicher viel
verein druckt und welche reise hat sie
am meisten geprägt würden sie sagen das
kann man schwer sagen aber was mir
wahnsinnig gut gefallen hat war nicht
wahr
parma in äthiopien das fand ich ganz
großartig sind dennoch länder auf deiner
bucket list seine top 3 ja absolut also
nummer 1 wer japan nämlich schon seit
bestimmt zehn jahren hin
ein paar sind nur übrig und das ist auf
jeden fall zum beispiel australien
neuseeland also ganz weit weg da mache
ich noch nicht wir haben eigentlich
voraussetzen bulli zu holen und ein
bisschen durch europa zu reisen
das skandinavien auf jeden fall also sie
wollen eigentlich keine pauschalurlaub
immer machen sondern wirklich irgendwie
im bulli und dann einfach losfahren und
gucken wo man so landet island in kanada
gibt es noch länder die auf ihrer bucket
list stehen wo sie unbedingt hin wein
also ich bin fan von südamerika ich bin
auch ein großer fan der spanischen
sprache oder der spanische gesprochenen
länder und von daher stehen die noch auf
meiner liste
auch wenn es dann irgendwie geht wenn
man willkommen ist australien ja auch
noch gerne aber ist eigentlich das
zweite ziel darstellen da braucht man
sehr lange davon dass das reicht nicht
immer ich hätte ja nach indien nach
vietnam und nach afrika
was kann ich noch nicht genau eigentlich
jetzt ein wonach trägt so ein bisschen
die kernregion skandinavien asien ja
finnland island sind sie eher natur
abenteuer wir mögen schon natur gibt es
noch andere länder wo du gerne hin
wollen würdest brasilien zum beispiel
ans geländer eigentlich ja kann ich also
fast alle länder dich noch nicht bereist
habe eigentlich genau
alina durch das heute zum ersten mal vor
der kamera
hier war easy german wie war's also am
anfang war ich sehr nervös aber es gegen
total wenn man gemerkt hat die leute
haben auch interesse zu antworten
und weil ich so eine gute einleitung
komme sehr detailliert und ja es war
sehr lustig und die leute haben auch
viele geschichten von janus gehört also
sie konnten gar nicht weg und jetzt
freuen wir uns von euch zu hören was war
denn eure interessanteste reise was wir
vielleicht euer größter kulturschock war
das zum beispiel in deutschland in der
eu
als sie von menschen angestarrt wurdet
oder unfreundlich bedient wurde
solche kulturschocks passieren ja auch
in deutschland schreibt uns einen
kommentar wir freuen uns auf eure
geschichten und ihr könnt unbedingt
alinas instagram kanal mal aus checken
den link findet ihr hier unten und
werdet bitte unbedingt ein mitglied von
easy german denn dann denn dann helft
ihr uns videos weiterzumachen und ihr
helft euch in dem ihr euer deut
verbessert mit unseren lernmaterialien
dann gewiss zuschauer bis bald
[Musik]